sabemos que las cargas eléctricas crean
campos eléctricos en el espacio que las
rodea pero las personas se confunden con
los problemas de campo eléctrico así que
tenemos que ser buenos en al menos dos
cosas para poder resolver bien estos
problemas debemos ser buenos en
determinar la dirección del campo
eléctrico creado por una carga si
tenemos una carga y queremos saber en
qué dirección se encuentra el campo
eléctrico creado por esta carga debemos
hacernos buenos en identificarla y si
conocen la dirección de un campo
eléctrico deben ser buenos encontrando
la dirección de la fuerza eléctrica
ejercida en una carga si tenemos una
carga que está flotando en un campo
eléctrico ustedes podrían decir bueno ya
sé cómo determinar la fuerza eléctrica
sin problema así que hay que hacerse
hábiles en saber cómo encontrar estas
dos cosas y así los problemas de campo
eléctrico van a ser mucho más fáciles y
además todo el proceso tendrá más
sentido como encontramos estos bueno
veamos el primero veamos cómo encontrar
la dirección de un campo eléctrico
creado por una carga digamos que este es
el campo eléctrico que es generado por
esta carga alrededor de ella cómo es que
podemos saber que es así el campo
eléctrico generado por esta carga bueno
podemos decir que conocemos la
definición del campo eléctrico y es la
cantidad de fuerza eléctrica ejercida
por carga es decir si tenemos una carga
de prueba podemos imaginarnos esta q
como nuestra carga de prueba y
usualmente nuestra carga de prueba va a
ser positiva ya que es más fácil de
conceptualizar la así tenemos una carga
de prueba positiva que pondremos en una
región la ponemos aquí la tomamos y la
movemos alrededor todo lo que tenemos
que hacer para conocer la dirección del
campo eléctrico ya que esta carga q es
positiva podemos deducir cuál será la
dirección de la fuerza eléctrica en esta
carga es decir la dirección del campo
eléctrico
va a tener la misma dirección que la
fuerza eléctrica en una carga de prueba
positiva ya que si conocemos de
ecuaciones vectoriales vean que el campo
eléctrico es un vector y la fuerza
eléctrica también es un vector este
campo eléctrico va a adoptar la
dirección de esta fuerza eléctrica
siempre y cuando esta q sea positiva si
está q es negativa va a cambiar el signo
de este vector de la fuerza eléctrica y
entonces va a apuntar en la dirección
opuesta pero si mantenemos nuestra carga
de prueba positiva sabremos que el campo
eléctrico va a apuntar a la misma
dirección que tenga la fuerza eléctrica
en nuestra carga de prueba positiva es
decir aquí tengo mi carga de prueba
positiva la estoy moviendo por acá y si
quiero conocer la dirección del campo
eléctrico en este punto de aquí me
pregunto en qué dirección está apuntando
la fuerza eléctrica en esta carga de
prueba en este caso la dirección de la
fuerza eléctrica va a ser
a la derecha ya que estás siendo
repelida por la carga positiva que
tenemos aquí así que yo sé que esta
fuerza eléctrica tiene la dirección
hacia la derecha porque estas cargas se
repelen y ya que la fuerza eléctrica
apunta hacia la derecha entonces el
campo eléctrico también va a apuntar
hacia la derecha
al menos en esta región quizá no tenga
la misma magnitud la fuerza eléctrica
podría ser de 20 newtons y el campo
eléctrico quizás sea de 10 newtons por
colom pero tienen una misma dirección y
puedo mover esta carga a otra posición
por ejemplo acá y hacia dónde apuntar a
la fuerza eléctrica pues estas cargas
positivas se siguen repeliendo así que
sigo teniendo una fuerza eléctrica hacia
la derecha con una magnitud menor que en
el ejemplo anterior pero seguirá
apuntando hacia la derecha por lo que el
campo eléctrico también va a estar
apuntando hacia la derecha aquí será más
pequeño también pero seguirá apuntando
hacia la derecha en este punto y si
queremos conocer la dirección de la
fuerza
eléctrica o el campo eléctrico en
cualquier otro lugar pues ponemos
nuestra carga de prueba en el lugar que
nos interesa conocer y nos preguntamos
cuál será la dirección de la fuerza
eléctrica actuando en esta carga de
prueba pues irá en esta dirección ya que
estas cargas se siguen repeliendo esta
carga está empujando hacia afuera a esta
otra carga positiva por lo que el campo
eléctrico en este punto también va a
estar apuntando hacia esta dirección y
seguimos haciendo esto ahora ponemos
nuestra carga por aquí las cargas se
repelen por lo que la fuerza eléctrica
va a tener esta dirección hacia abajo
por lo que nuestro campo eléctrico
también va a apuntar hacia abajo y si
seguimos haciendo esto de encontrar la
dirección del campo eléctrico en una
carga de prueba positiva alrededor de
esta carga eventualmente nos daremos
cuenta de que el campo eléctrico siempre
va a radiar hacia afuera de la carga y
así sabemos que el campo eléctrico de
una carga positiva va a apuntar radio
hacia fuera de esta carga y es por eso
que la dibujamos de esta forma esta
carga positiva va a repeler cualquier
otra carga positiva que se encuentre
alrededor de ella la va a empujar
radialmente hacia afuera pero qué tal si
la carga que está creando el campo
eléctrico fuera una carga negativa vamos
a encontrarla digamos que esta es mi
carga de prueba y la carga que está
creando el campo eléctrico va a ser
negativa y más grande como determinamos
la dirección del campo eléctrico
alrededor de esta carga negativa pues
hacemos lo mismo
tomamos nuestra carga de prueba positiva
y la colocamos en un punto alrededor de
nuestra carga negativa y nuestra carga
de prueba seguirá siendo positiva porque
así nos aseguramos de que la dirección
de la fuerza eléctrica en esta carga de
prueba positiva tendrá la misma
dirección que el campo eléctrico en esta
región en otras palabras el que esta
carga sea positiva nos va a garantizar
que tanto el campo eléctrico como la
fuerza eléctrica apunten en la misma
dirección así que
vemos nuestra carga de prueba y la
ponemos aquí qué dirección tiene la
fuerza eléctrica en esta carga de prueba
en esta ocasión esta carga va a sentirse
atraída hacia nuestra carga negativa
cargas opuestas se atraen por lo que la
fuerza eléctrica va a apuntar hacia esta
dirección a la izquierda y como mi carga
de prueba es positiva y preserva la
dirección del campo eléctrico que es
igual a la de la fuerza eléctrica quiere
decir que mi campo eléctrico también va
a apuntar hacia la izquierda
vamos a seguir describiendo el campo
eléctrico y ponemos nuestra carga de
prueba positiva aquí en este caso la
fuerza eléctrica va a apuntar hacia
arriba porque esta carga positiva va a
ser atraída por mi carga negativa y si
la fuerza eléctrica apunta hacia arriba
entonces el campo eléctrico también va a
apuntar hacia arriba y si hacemos esto
nos daremos cuenta de que una carga
negativa siempre va a jalar o va a traer
hacia ella cualquier carga de prueba
positiva que se encuentre alrededor suyo
así que la fuerza eléctrica va a ir
hacia el centro de mi carga positiva y
por lo tanto la dirección del campo
eléctrico también tendrá esta dirección
así que el campo eléctrico generado por
una carga negativa siempre va a apuntar
radialmente hacia el centro de esta
carga así que una carga positiva siempre
va a crear un campo eléctrico que va
radialmente hacia afuera de ella porque
siempre va a repeler cualquier carga de
prueba positiva en cambio cuando nuestra
carga principal es negativa va a atraer
hacia sí esta carga de prueba positiva
por lo que el campo eléctrico generado
por esta carga siempre va a ir
radialmente hacia el centro de esta
básicamente lo que quiero decir es que
voy a quitar todo esto el campo
eléctrico de una carga positiva siempre
va a apuntar radialmente hacia afuera de
esta pero si tenemos una carga negativa
tenemos que borrar todas estas cabezas
de flecha y poner
en el otro extremo ya que el campo
eléctrico de una carga negativa siempre
va a apuntar hacia adentro radialmente
hacia adentro de esta carga así que el
campo eléctrico creado por una carga
negativa en cualquier punto del espacio
alrededor de ella va a apuntar hacia el
centro de esta carga negativa y es así
como determinamos la dirección del campo
eléctrico creado por una carga si es una
carga positiva sabemos que su campo
eléctrico va a estar apuntando
radialmente hacia afuera de esta carga y
si es una carga negativa su campo
eléctrico va a estar apuntando
radialmente hacia adentro de esta carga
negativa muy bien ya sabemos cómo
encontrar este primer punto encontrar la
dirección de un campo eléctrico creado
por una carga tenemos que saber cómo
encontrar la dirección de una fuerza
eléctrica ejercida en una carga qué
quiere decir esto cómo lo vamos a hacer
digamos que tenemos una región en el
espacio en donde hay un campo eléctrico
que está apuntando hacia
no sabemos qué es lo que está creando
este campo eléctrico y realmente no
importa es por eso que está idea del
campo eléctrico es genial no necesito
conocer qué es lo que está creando este
campo eléctrico es decir podrían ser
cargas positivas aquí lo que hace que el
campo eléctrico apunte radialmente hacia
afuera de ellas o también podríamos
tener cargas negativas que estén creando
un campo eléctrico que vaya radialmente
hacia ellas o ambas a la vez no sabemos
y realmente no importa siempre y cuando
yo sepa que hay un campo eléctrico y que
está apuntando hacia la derecha podré
encontrar la dirección de la fuerza
eléctrica ejercida sobre una carga
dentro de este campo eléctrico así que
aquí ponemos nuestra carga de prueba
positiva y la movemos en este campo
eléctrico y ya que el campo eléctrico es
igual a la fuerza eléctrica en esa carga
dividida entre la misma carga
si esta carga que pusimos aquí es
positiva entonces la fuerza eléctrica
apunta en la misma dirección que el
campo eléctrico y viceversa el campo
eléctrico apunta en la misma dirección
que la fuerza eléctrica siempre y cuando
la carga que está sintiendo esta fuerza
sea una carga positiva lo que es una
forma larga de decir que la fuerza
eléctrica ejercida sobre una carga de
prueba positiva que se encuentra en un
campo eléctrico va a apuntar en la misma
dirección que la del campo eléctrico en
esa región si tenemos un campo eléctrico
que apunta hacia la derecha como el que
tenemos aquí entonces la fuerza
eléctrica también va a apuntar hacia la
derecha siempre y cuando mi carga de
prueba en esta región sea positiva y me
podrían decir caray que no es obvio esta
ecuación nos dice que el campo eléctrico
tiene la misma dirección que la fuerza
eléctrica podríamos decir que sí pero no
del todo hay una excepción si esta carga
de aquí fuera negativa si aquí abajo
tenemos una carga
entonces la dirección de la fuerza
eléctrica cuando este vector de fuerza
se multiplica por un signo negativo
aunque aquí está siendo dividido por un
número negativo dividir entre menos 1 es
como multiplicar por menos 1 vamos a
cambiar la dirección de este vector
fuerza y nuestro campo eléctrico va a
apuntar en la dirección opuesta a la de
la fuerza eléctrica que esté actuando
sobre una carga negativa en esta región
esto puede ser algo confuso
así que vean esto digamos que ponemos
una carga negativa en esta región y
queremos conocer cuál será la dirección
de la fuerza eléctrica actuando en esta
carga negativa sobre esta región de este
campo eléctrico nuestro campo eléctrico
apunta hacia la derecha y esta q de acá
es negativa por lo que la fuerza
eléctrica va a tener que apuntar hacia
la izquierda y la razón es que si este
vector de fuerza va hacia la izquierda y
lo dividimos entre un signo negativo va
a hacer que este vector fuerza cambie su
dirección de la izquierda
a la derecha lo que significa que el
campo eléctrico va a apuntar hacia la
derecha así que si la cadena que
experimenta la fuerza eléctrica es
negativa debido a que si multiplicamos
un vector por menos 1 le cambiamos la
dirección la fuerza eléctrica en el
campo eléctrico tendrá dirección opuesta
por lo que una carga negativa va a
experimentar una fuerza que va en la
dirección opuesta a la del campo
eléctrico pero una carga positiva va a
sentir la fuerza eléctrica en la misma
dirección que la del campo eléctrico
vamos a repetirlo porque es importante
las cargas positivas experimentan una
fuerza eléctrica en la misma dirección
que la del campo eléctrico y las cargas
negativas experimentan una fuerza
eléctrica en la dirección opuesta a la
del campo eléctrico y las personas
confunden esto todo el tiempo y aquí hay
una forma que les ayudará a evitar estas
confusiones vean que ninguna de estas
cargas es la que está creando el campo
eléctrico que está
siendo una fuerza sobre ellas así que
vamos a dibujar algunas cargas que
podrían estar creando este campo
eléctrico una forma de crear un campo
eléctrico que va hacia la derecha es
poner varias cargas positivas de este
lado cada una de ellas crea un campo
eléctrico que está radiando hacia fuera
de ellas lo que crearía un campo
eléctrico que va hacia la derecha igual
sería la fuerza sobre estas cargas
sabemos que las cargas con el mismo
signo se repelen por lo que aquí la
fuerza eléctrica va hacia la derecha y
las cargas positivas atraen a las cargas
negativas por lo que en este caso la
fuerza eléctrica va a ir hacia la
izquierda por lo que esta convención de
que la fuerza eléctrica tiene la misma
dirección que el campo eléctrico para
una carga positiva y la fuerza eléctrica
que apunta en la dirección opuesta a la
del campo eléctrico para cargas
negativas es congruente con lo que ya
sabemos sobre la atracción de las cargas
opuestas y las
pulsión de las cargas iguales y es por
eso que a veces las personas se
confunden cuando no dibujan las cargas
que pueden estar creando el campo
eléctrico pues cuál es la dirección de
la fuerza eléctrica para cada carga en
ese campo si ustedes quieren pueden
siempre dibujar estas cargas que podrían
crear el campo eléctrico otra
posibilidad para crear campos eléctricos
que van hacia la derecha es tener aquí
varias cargas negativas éstas podrían
estar creando este campo eléctrico ya
que las cargas negativas crean campos
eléctricos que van radialmente hacia
adentro de ellas y cuál sería la
dirección de las fuerzas aquí pues las
cargas negativas van a estar atrayendo
esta carga positiva por lo que la fuerza
eléctrica va a ir hacia la derecha como
habíamos visto va a tener la misma
dirección que la del campo eléctrico ya
sea que este campo eléctrico sea creado
por cargas negativas o por cargas
positivas esto no importa si el campo
eléctrico va hacia la derecha las cargas
positivas sentirán una fuerza eléctrica
que irá hacia él
y una carga negativa en esta región va a
sentirse repelido por estas cargas
negativas de acá o sentirse atraída por
estas cargas positivas de aquí de
cualquier manera va a sentir una fuerza
eléctrica que va hacia la izquierda así
que no importa si son cargas positivas o
cargas negativas las que están creando
este campo eléctrico si el campo
eléctrico apunta hacia una dirección las
cargas positivas en ese campo eléctrico
tendrán una fuerza eléctrica que apunta
en la misma dirección que el campo y las
cargas negativas en esa región van a
sentir una fuerza eléctrica que está en
la dirección opuesta a la del campo
hagamos otro ejemplo más para practicar
digamos que tenemos esto es una carga
negativa que está experimentando una
fuerza eléctrica que va hacia abajo y
queremos conocer la dirección del campo
eléctrico en esta región si la dirección
de la fuerza eléctrica en esta carga
negativa es hacia abajo la única manera
para que esto ocurra es tener un campo
eléctrico que vaya hacia arriba ya que
las cargas negativas
una fuerza eléctrica que va en sentido
opuesto a la dirección del campo
eléctrico en esa región la dirección d
va a ser opuesta a la dirección de f
cuando q es negativa si nos preguntamos
qué carga ocasionaría que esta otra
carga tuviera una fuerza con dirección
hacia abajo si esta carga es negativa
pues una gran carga positiva aquí abajo
podría generar esto las cargas positivas
generan un campo eléctrico que va
radialmente hacia afuera de ellas por lo
que en esta región el campo eléctrico
que va radialmente hacia afuera iría
hacia arriba ya que se alejan de la
carga positiva o podremos pensar en otra
cosa que causa una fuerza eléctrica
sobre una carga negativa que va hacia
abajo pues podría ser otra carga
negativa que se encuentre aquí arriba y
las cargas negativas siempre crean
campos eléctricos que van radialmente
hacia adentro de ellas porque el campo
eléctrico en esta región iría también
hacia
ya que hacia arriba en esta región es
radialmente hacia adentro de esta carga
negativa
en resumen pueden encontrar la dirección
de un campo eléctrico creado por una
carga recordando que las cargas
positivas crean un campo eléctrico que
va radialmente hacia afuera de ellas y
las cargas negativas crean un campo
eléctrico que va radialmente hacia
adentro de ellas y pueden encontrar la
dirección de la fuerza eléctrica
ejercida sobre una carga si tienen
cargas positivas una carga positiva va a
tener una fuerza eléctrica que va en la
misma dirección que el campo eléctrico
en el que se encuentra y las cargas
negativas van a tener una fuerza
eléctrica en dirección opuesta a la del
campo eléctrico en esa región